und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend diese EU muss
sterben damit das wahre Europa leben
kann das sagte Björn höcke heute in
Magdeburg wo sich die AFD zum
Bundesparteitag trifft damit dürfte klar
sein wohin der Kurs der Partei in Sachen
EU gehen wird denn der Vorsitzende aus
Thüringen gilt ja als heimliche
machtinstanz in der AFD passend dazu
wurde heute ein Mann zum
Spitzenkandidaten für die Europawahl
gewählt der Positionen des
rechtsextremen Lagers vertritt und auch
vor Aussagen die selbst in der AFD
umstritten sind nicht zurückschreckt
zudem plädiert gerade dafür dass die AFD
sich auf keinen Fall mäßigen solle
begleitet wird der Parteitag wie immer
eigentlich von Demonstrationen Andreas
Weise
Tag 2 in Magdeburg lautstarke Protest
gegen die AFD in der
sachsen-anhaltischen Landeshauptstadt
dass die Parteien Umfragen bundesweit
und speziell im Osten so stark ist
beunruhigt die meisten hier ich finde
mit einer Partei die offene Hetze die
offenen Hass die offen Panikmache
betreibt da liefert man ihr nur eine
Bühne mit ihr zusammenarbeitet und
liefert ihr eine Steilvorlage sozusagen
nach der nächsten Steilvorlagen gab es
heute auch einige in der Magdeburger
Messehalle Europa ist nun das Thema dass
die AFD EU und Euro nicht will seit
ihrer Gründung Markenkern der Partei
doch ganz ohne Europa geht es auch für
die Rechtspopulisten nicht wir müssen
eine Festung Europa bauen wir brauchen
die Festung Europa zum Schutz unserer
Heimat und das machen wir gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen Partnern liebe
Freunde
oft auch zuständig für populistische
Zuspitzungen einer der erst heute nach
Magdeburg kam der thüringische Partei
Rechtsaußen Björn höcke
es gibt viele gute Gründe jenseits der
Kostengründe diese EU abzulehnen sie
bringt Europa nicht weiter und wenn sie
von mir meine populistische Aussage
hören wollen dann kann ich Ihnen das in
einer Aussage zusammenpacken diese EU
muss sterben damit das wahre Europa
leben kann da bin ich überzeugt dass man
aber mit der radikalen Europa Thesen
zurzeit wieder hierzulande noch in
Brüssel mehrheitsfähig ist weißer höcke
in der Sache und im Inhalt sind wir
weiterhin deutlich und klar akzentuiert
aber der Prozess ist natürlich ein
organischer das heißt ein ein
sukzessiver und muss angebahnt werden
Hauptpunkt heute die Liste für die
Europawahl im kommenden Jahr an der
Spitze nun ein durchaus umstrittener
Kandidat Maximilian Krah der punktet mit
nationaltönen
wir sind ein Volk weil wenn wir uns
unsere Familienalben zeigen dann
erkennen wir das schon unsere Großväter
und ihre unsere Urgroßväter ein Volk
sind wir sprechen dieselbe Sprache wir
fühlen und denken in denselben Worten
uns wurden dieselben Märchen vorgelesen
und dieselben Lieder vorgesungen dass
die AFD in Europa Teil der idee-partei
wird einem rechtspopulistischen
Zusammenschluss dem unter anderem die
FPÖ angehört unterstützt werden
wir wollen in der
Idee bleiben wir wollen dass Sie größer
wird und wir wollen dass wir so stark
werden dass wir mit entscheiden
die Europäische Union quasi von ihnen
heraus auflösen das ist das Ziel nicht
nur der AFD sondern vieler
Rechtspopulisten euweit die Delegierten
haben nur noch einen Wahlmarathon vor
sich ist die Europaliste fertig und das
Wahlprogramm verabschiedet ist morgen
und das ganze kommende Wochenende nehmen
Sie sich die Zeit um das zu schaffen
wir machen weiter mit der Frage wohin
mit dem Müll vor fast sechs Monaten
bebte die Erde in Syrien und in der
Türkei ja gleich mehrmals 60.000 Tote
wurden geborgen Millionen Menschen
verloren ihr Dach über den Kopf mehr als
200.000 Gebäude sollen zerstört worden
sein besonders betroffen war die Region
Hatay dort ist man unermüdlich mit
Aufbau und auf Räumarbeiten beschäftigt
doch es geht sehr langsam voran auch
wegen Staub und Schutt und der ist dann
auch noch teilweise Asbest verseucht
Anna Feist
dieser Staub ist giftig voller Asbest
Quecksilber und Blei aus dem Mauerwerk
und technischen Geräten die
miteinstürzen Aufräumarbeiten in der
Region Hatay im türkischen
Erdbebengebiet Bauunternehmer will kann
Aslam soll mit seinen 37 Maschinen und
den 92 Arbeitern bis Ende des Jahres
500.000 Quadratmeter Räumen anders als
viele andere in der Stadt versucht er
die Bevölkerung zu schützen staubt
möglichst zu vermeiden wässert trotz
Wasser Knappheit
alles bewässern es ist unmöglich
wirklich allen Staub zu ersticken er
nimmt uns mit durch eine Stadt die
eigentlich Sperrzone sein sollte
92% von Antakya sind zerstört die
türkische Regierung hat ihn wieder
Aufbau beschlossen das war Erdogans
wahlversprechend doch erst müssen alle
Schwerbeschädigten Häuser abgerissen
werden um den Zeitplan einzuhalten
arbeiten sie doppelt so schnell wie
unter normalen Bedingungen
wenn es die Menschen hier nicht geben
würde dann könnte man die Stadt komplett
isolieren und eine Baustelle aus ihr
machen aber so müssen wir oft auf die
Bremse Drücken
der Bauingenieur bringt uns zu riesigen
Schutt halten wo das Metall aus dem
Stein geholt wird denn das bringe Geld
der giftige Bauschutt er lagert in der
gesamten Region in Wohngebieten auf
landwirtschaftlich genutzten Flächen
selbst am Strand dort wo eins der
tourismusblüte
halten sollten nicht da sein wo sie
derzeit sind
Mustafa östek war Staatssekretär im
türkischen Umweltministerium schon
Wochen nach dem Leben schlägt er Alarm
durch die willkürlich ausgewählten
Plätze seien nun Flüsse
küstenfeuchtgebiete und Grundwasser
verseucht Schwermetallvergiftungen
drohen
Lungenerkrankungen und
Atemwegsinfektionen werden zunehmen wir
rechnen damit dass es mehr Fehlgeburten
geben wird
wir wollen vom Bürgermeister von Hatay
erfahren wie es soweit kommen konnte und
warum die Bevölkerung nicht vor der
drohenden Katastrophe gewarnt wird
diese strategischen Entscheidungen
trifft der Staat aber was wenn Sie die
entscheidende Kraft wären hätte ich die
Entscheidungsvollmacht würde ich die
Gesundheit zur Priorität machen hartei
komplett evakuieren und so schnell wie
möglich wieder aufbauen
so bahnt sich in Hatay nach der
Katastrophe eine neue Katastrophe an die
die Gesundheit derer kosten könnte die
das Beben überlebt haben
und in den Nachrichten geht der erste
Blick Gundula in die Ukraine
im Südosten der Ukraine verläuft die
gegen Offensive des angegriffenen Landes
offenbar recht zäh hier räumte ein die
Kämpfe seien schwierig nach kleineren
erfolgen an der Front hat Präsident
selenski den Soldaten dort gedankt er
besuchte nach eigenen Angaben vor
gerückte Stellungen bei bachmut und
vergab Auszeichnungen bachmut war im Mai
von den russischen Truppen eingenommen
worden und ist durch die heftigen Kämpfe
weitgehend zerstört
die USA haben Militärhilfen für Taiwan
in Höhe von umgerechnet fast 315
Millionen Euro angekündigt die
Ausrüstung etwa zur Aufklärung kommt
direkt aus dem militärbeständigen der
USA auch Australien soll von den USA
stärker militärisch unterstützt werden
die us-minister blinken und Austin
rechtfertigten die Hilfen mit dem
chinesischen Machtanspruch im Pazifik
und in Südostasien
in Israel haben sich landesweit erneut
hunderttausende zu Protesten gegen die
umstrittene Justizreform versammelt
allein in Tel Aviv sind 160.000 Menschen
auf den Straßen trotz massiver Kritik
hatte die rechtsreligiöse Regierung ein
Gesetz verabschiedet dass die Befugnisse
des Obersten Gerichts einschränkt
kritiker sehen die Demokratie in Israel
in Gefahr
der in der Nordsee in Brand geratene
Auto fragte soll in sichere Gewässer
gezogen werden
Bergungsteams wollen den Frachter noch
an diesem Wochenende zu einer
Ankerposition bei schiermonnikook
bringen so sollen kentern und
Auseinanderbrechen des Schiffes und
somit eine Umweltkatastrophe in der
Nordsee verhindert werden
in Upahl in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben
rund 100 Bürger erneut gegen den Bau
einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft protestiert
seit Anfang des Jahres versucht ein
Großteil der 500 Einwohner des Ortes das
Vorhaben zu stoppen ohne Erfolg die
ersten Container sollen Anfang August
aufgestellt werden insgesamt sollen in
opal rund 250 Asylbewerber untergebracht
werden
die einen sind zum Vögeln hingefahren
andere wollten Gaudi sagte mal Klaus
Renft Gründer der gleichnamigen DDR
Rockband über das sogenannte rote
Woodstock Festival das vor 50 Jahren in
der DDR stattfand 8 Millionen waren
damals nach Ostberlin gekommen um bei
den Weltfestspielen der Jugend dabei zu
sein viele hatten die Hoffnung dass es
vorwärts geht politisch war die Zeit
geprägt von der deutsch-deutschen
Annäherung unterbrannt und so ging es
dort nicht nur um Spaß und um Musik
sondern auch um Politik und das wiederum
ging nicht an der Staatssicherheit
vorbei über 4.000 hauptamtliche
Mitarbeitende der Stasi überwachten das
Festival das dennoch für viele
unvergessen bleibt Christa Läpple
so etwas hatte Ostberlin noch nicht
erlebt ein Hauch von weiter Welt an neun
Tagen scheint alles möglich
hunderttausende stehen Kopf Larven peace
auf dem Alex die Lütte Angelika Mann
gerade mal 24 covert Tina
[Musik]
also mit sowas hat man im Leben ja nicht
gerechnet dass einem das passiert und
die waren ja auch alle gut drauf also es
war gute Laune das war glaube ich nie so
gute Laune an der DDR wie zu dem
Zeitpunkt Angelika Mann wird diese
Stunden am Alex in die vergessen
die Hauptstadt der DDR im
Ausnahmezustand 8 Millionen Besucher aus
140 Ländern
1500 Straßenfeste Konzerte und fuhren
über das rote Woodstock heißt es bald
die Welt Festspiele werden zu waren
fällt Bett spielen mit langen Haaren
kurzen Rücken und noch mehr Leidenschaft
man nannte es auch aber die ABBA
Festspiele und zwar
ankommen brüllen bumsen abfahren das
darf man das sagen darf man sagen
natürlich sind die weltfestspiele für
honeggers SED eine riesige
propaganda-show im Vorfeld hatte die
Stasi genau
2293 potenzielle Störenfriede aus dem
Verkehr ziehen lassen doch für Millionen
Menschen bedeuten diese 9 Tage ein
Hoffnungsschimmer ein Versprechen für
eine andere bessere und weltoffene DDR
die weltverspielung das war glücklich da
haben wir gelebt und getobt und
gequatscht und Freiheiten genossen die
wir uns danach nicht mehr haben ganz
nehmen lassen
unvorstellbar rund um die Weltzeituhr
wird wild diskutiert die Junge Union
verteilt Flugblätter mittendrin der
spätere regierende Bürgermeisterwahl es
gibt keine Tabus und niemand wird
verhaftet
heute keine DDR 61
der Junge Westberliner ruhen will über
Stalinismus reden
ein richtiges Gespräch kam nicht
zustande das Ende war was wollen Sie
erreichen so in dem Tenor wurde ich dann
auch zum Schluss befragt
das Festival Lied singt Schlagerstar
Frank Schöbel
wer die Erde liebt war das nun der
glücklichste Moment der DDR nein meint
er heute 80-Jährige ja der glücklichste
war ganz sicher die Öffnung die
Maueröffnung 89 also
da ging nichts rüber als zweiter
Ulbricht während der weltfestspiele
stirbt nimmt kaum jemand Notiz davon die
Zeichen stehen auf Neuanfang doch diese
Chance nutzt Nachfolger Erich Honecker
nicht mit dem Ende des Festivals war der
Zauber vorbei
[Musik]
das neue Ausbildungsjahr steht vor der
Tür und noch im Juni waren
256.000 Lehrstellen nicht besetzt
zugleich haben laut Bundesagentur für
Arbeit rund
147.000 Bewerber noch keinen passenden
Ausbildungsplatz gefunden vor allem im
Einzelhandel und im Handwerk in
Metallberufen und auf dem Bau gibt es
noch Zehntausende freie
Ausbildungsplätze
und wir haben jetzt die gewinnzahlen vom
Lotto sie lauten ohne Gewähr 3 10 19 33
41 45 Superzahl 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 556 und das Wetter bleibt in den
nächsten Tagen unbeständig kräftige
Schauer und Gewitter gibt es morgen von
der Lausitz bis zu den Alpen sowie im
Norden und Nordwesten sonst wird es
meist freundlich bei böigem Westwind 19
bis 25 Grad am Montag bei bis zu 25 Grad
im Norden Regen im Süden länger sonnig
ab Dienstag wechselhaft und windig mit
kräftigen Schauern und Gewittern und
etwas kühler
da geht der Hund morgen alleine raus
aber wir bleiben noch beim jetzt denn
jetzt folgt das aktuelle sportstudio mit
ihrem Dreier und direkt danach um kurz
nach Mitternacht meldet sich Christopher
Wehrmann mit einer heute Express bis
morgen machen sie es gut tschüss
[Musik]